SEED, THEY AVOID THE PLAY-IN
TOURNAMENT.
>> AND YOU DON'T WANT TO PLAY
PHOENIX OR GOLDEN STATE IN THE
FIRST ROUND.
ANYBODY ELSE, I FEEL LIKE THE
LAKERS FEEL THEY CAN BEAT THEM.
>> THEY WON FRIDAY AGAINST
ORLANDO, THE CLIP THAT WAS BEING
SHARED EVERYWHERE, YOU AND RUSS
CHOPPING IT UP.
WHOEVER RECORDED IT WAS TALKING
SO MUCH, WE COULDN'T HEAR.
WHAT WERE YOU GUYS TALKING
ABOUT.
>> SHAQ, ARE THOSE FLOWERS?
>> YES, FROM THE BAHAMAS.
PEOPLE THINK WE WERE HAVING AN
ARGUMENT, OR A BEEF.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
I LOVE RUSS, I CARE ABOUT RUSS,
AND WHEN YOU'RE NOT PLAYING
WELL, PEOPLE TAKE SHOTS.
I DON'T LIKE SEEING PEOPLE
COMING AT MY GUY.
I WAS WATCHING HIM, ANALYZING
HIM, I SAID, SLOW DOWN.
THE ONE PLAY, HE STARTS THE FAST
BREAK BACK THERE, AND HE'S FAST,
BUT NOT AS FAST AS THE OLD RUSS.
THEN THE YOUNG GUY CAUGHT UP
WITH HIM, IT'S LIKE, BRO, TAKE
YOUR TIME, SLOW IT DOWN, THEN
EXPLODE.
IF YOU START BACK AT 94 FEET
FULL SPEED, THE GUY WILL TURN.
SLOW DOWN, TAKE YOUR TIME.
>> HOW DID HE RESPOND?
>> HE SAID, MAN, YOU KNOW, I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET IN A RHYTHM.
I SAID, NO, SLOW DOWN.
SLOW YOUR GAME DOWN, PACE
YOURSELF.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO A MILLION
MILES AN HOUR.
>> DID HE LISTEN AFTER THAT?
>> HE HAD A COUPLE OF PLAYS, BUT
HE SCORED, HE PLAYED WELL.
CARMELO HEATED UP THAT NIGHT.
>> 19 IN THE SECOND HALF.
>> THAT'S HIS ONLY PROBLEM.
HE JUST NEEDS TO SLOW DOWN.
LIKE, YOU KNOW, WHEN I FIRST GOT
THERE, HE SHOT THE BANK SHOT,
HIT THE TOP OF THE RIM.
HE WAS EVEN RUSHING THAT.
IT'S LIKE, TAKE YOUR TIME, YOU
KNOW HOW TO SHOOT, YOU'VE BEEN
IN BIG MOMENTS BEFORE.
JUST S